wenn ihr Cherrytomaten übrig habt dann
müsst ihr diese Pasta machen und das ist
alles was wir brauchen Cherrytomaten
Olivenöl Basilikum Nudeln ein bisschen
Knoblauch Chili wir nehmen unsere
Cherrytomaten geben Sie in eine große
Pfanne darüber ordentlich Olivenöl jetzt
müssen wir nur noch warten passt alles
im Topf und die Koch während unsere Soße
fertig wird
die ersten Tomaten ist der fallen schon
aber wir helfen ein bisschen nach jetzt
gebe ich noch Knoblauch und Chili dazu
geben wir die Nudeln zur Soße wir geben
sie mit ordentlich Nudelwasser dran und
vermischen WoW und jetzt entsteht unsere
Soße durch Nudelwasser und die
eingekochten Tomaten mit zupfen ein
bisschen frischen Basilikum rein guckt
euch diese Soße an fertig ist unsere